ورقه الشتاء تلعب على اكثر من جبهه ومنها
جبهه التدفئه والغاز الروسيه المنقطعه عن
اوروبا الخوف كل الخوف من الشتاء قادم
الصعب للغايه لكن هل تتخيل ان الشتاء هذا
العام سيكون رحيما بشتاء يعني 2023
المعلومه صادمه نعم لكن الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه اكدت ان اوروبا نجحت في تخزينه 90%
من متطلبات الشتاء القادم من الغاز لكن
القادم هو تاكيد الخبراء ان غالبيه الغاز
المخزن مصدر وروسيا وهو لن يكون متوفرا في
الشتاء 2023 وحتى البدائل التي تحاول
اوروبا
اليها من اجل الغاز صعبه الصين مثلا احجبت
عن شراء كميه الغاز المتعاقد عليها بعد ان
شهد اقتصادها تراجع عنه وهو قد لا يحدث في
العام المقبل والعهده على شركه الايطاليه
المدير التنفيذيه للشركه الايطاليه توقع
ان تزداد رق الاحتجاجات الاجتماعيه العام
المقبل بعد ان بات غالبيه الاوروبيين
يدفعون 50% من مداخلها على الطاقه
الاوروبيون اباتو يدفعون في بعض البلدان
اسعارا اغلى بخمسه عشره مرات مما يدفعه
الامريكيون مقابل الغاز والنتيجه غلاء في
كل شيء وبريطانيا
طره للتخلي عن وجبه واحده على الاقل يوميا
خلال الثلاثه اشهر الماضيه فيما لجا
ملايين اخرون الى التقليل من كميات الاكل
المستهلكه او عدم الاقتراس بنوعيها هذا
يعني ان 40% من المستفيدين من الدعم
الحكومي يفوتنا وجبه واحده على الاقل
يوميا ثمانيه وثلاثون بالمئه قالوا انهم
لم يتمكنوا من شراء ما يكفي من الطعام
فيما لم يستخدم واحد 28% من الناس غاز
الطهي بسبب خلايا اسعار الطاقه بنوك
الطعام من جانبها قالت انها زادت نسبه
فروض الطعام المقدمه للمحتاجين لمسته 50%
مقارنه بما قبل وبعد كورونا حكومه
بريطانيا
عشرات المليارات من الجنيهات لكن
الاجراءات هذه لم تعد كافيه
اجراءات الحكومه وضعت اربعه 34% من في
ديون لانهم لم يتمكنوا من مواكبه ارتفاع
فواتيرهم الاساسيه